the new governor from virginia glenn
younkin who won a couple months ago it
was close
he defeated what's-his-name who was that
guy the crazy guy with the dancing and
it looked like he was wearing lipstick
who was the guy he used to run the
democratic
i think he was the head of the dnc at
one time guy was a nut bag uh we'll get
his name in a second god all of these
people that they seem important that
you're supposed to know who they are and
then they lose and then you're just like
oh that guy like remember the guy who
ran for vice president with hillary
clinton like tom kane tim kaine nobody
remembers these people anymore because
you shouldn't know anything about these
people terry mcauliffe is the democrat
who was a complete lunatic who basically
said you shouldn't have any right to
your children's education what they're
learning in school and younkin did the
right thing he got involved in the
culture wars he stood up for something
and said that school choice is important
and we are not going to allow woke-ism
and critical race theory to brainwash a
generation and everything else well that
is very upsetting to the clowns over at
cnn and here's chief clown jim acosta uh
molly um you know i seem to remember
glenn younkin campaigning in a fleece
vest
in virginia he was running as a
different kind of republican i was told
there was going to be a vest
not a soviet-style police state across
the potomac from washington
journalism
it ain't what it used to be yes okay
acosta you see what he did there now
this is a man who purports to be a
journalist right i'm an impartial
journalist i am jim acosta at cnn a
place of journalism
also describing the new governor of
virginia as uh bringing in a quote
soviet-style police state across from
the potomac by the way the woman he's
talking to this molly jong fast lady i'm
pretty sure she's called me racist on
twitter a couple times and she used to
troll me all the time i think i muted or
blocked her doesn't matter um but you
see what they do like if you're just the
average cnn person watching that and
you're just sort of blue-pilled and not
really paying attention to what's going
on you'd be watching that and you'd be
going oh my oh my god
jim acosta's a bright man he's a he's a
good man and he just said that there's
some sort of soviet-style situation
happening in virginia this glen yonkin
must be a really bad dude
glenn younkin is literally forcing the
schools to give choice to the parents we
all know about everything that happened
there in lewd in virginia and all of the
stuff we all know all of the stuff
right so it's like we can either
choose what i would say are imperfect
republicans i have no doubt that i will
have disagreements with junkin and he
will most likely fail us in some ways of
course of course he will it's just how
it is
or we could choose democrats that don't
want you to have any choice in what your
children are learning and do you think
that over time
if you don't have any choice over what
your children are learning and there are
big tech companies that can force them
to see certain things and not see other
things and then there's a government
that can also influence those big tech
companies relative to what they can see
do you think you might be able to
actually change the way an entire
generation or perhaps even two
generations of people can think and do
you think maybe you could do that in
just a couple years and do you think if
you throw in a pandemic and sprinkle a
little fear on top of it do you think it
might lead to oh my god where we are
today